welcome to the first ever online wiesner
gallery tour my name is shannon rose
mcauliffe and i'm the manager of the
student arts programs here at mit
i'm also joined by sarah herzl who's the
coordinator of the wiesner student art
gallery
and tal mafildeshi and jongin sa both
graduates of the mit
school of architecture and planning
master's degree and they were class of
2020.
congratulations um this evening we're
pleased for them to present their
exhibition
called misalignments it's a multi-part
exploration
of materiality and fabrication both by
machine
and by hand dama and chung examine how
robots are affecting the texture of our
built environment
and demonstrate through their work some
ways that they might subvert
those trends after a brief introduction
by sarah
about the exhibition damma and jung will
lead us through their virtual show via
screen share
without further ado i'm going to pass it
over to sarah
my name is sarah herzl i'm the
coordinator of the wiesner student art
gallery which is a space open to any art
practitioners
i'm in any medium from any part of mit
who
currently enrolled as students so keep
that in mind if you're interested in
pursuing any kind of project of this
kind
back on march 11th i was really excited
because dalma and jung were busy
installing a show
in the wiesner gallery in w-20 in the
student center
we were going to have an opening the
following week they had plans for an
installation with custom-made podiums
they were going to shape the walls
all to support really exquisite work
that you're going to see here
the show was halfway built when we were
sent home
by the institute and though it's really
disappointing that we can't share these
really subtle and beautiful pieces with
all of you in person
i could not be more thrilled with the
way that they transformed that
exhibition into this
opportunity and i think that the site
that they made
as a gallery ha really illuminates their
research their process
and their vision for all of us as you'll
see
these two architect artists are they are
unusually well suited
to bridge the gap between the handmade
or the in-person experience
and the mechanized world of technology
they were the perfect candidates for
this to solve this problem
so leave it to them to take our
expectations and turn them upside down
i'm really grateful that they're here to
help us re-envision what the wiesner can
be
right now at this moment um so without
further ado i just would like to
introduce
jung and sa and dalman foldishi and um
i'd like to begin by asking the two of
you to share a really basic introduction
to what you do
in layman's terms especially for people
who've never seen your work before
thank you for the introductions shannon
rose and sarah i'm doma
and i'm jung thank you for joining us
today
we're really excited for this
opportunity and what we're showing you
today is
grounded in the work that began as part
of our master's thesis at mit
we reformatted it for this virtual show
and we're
very much honored to be part of the arts
and the radar
and so the thank yous we really want to
thank everyone who
helped make this possible so huge thank
you to sarah
lydia andrea and heidi from what's at
mit
and also to our advisors who are not
here yet i don't think um mariana axel
and mark
and then also to the ceramics studios at
mit so daryl jay and
thank you graeme who's here here also
today um
and also at harvard nathan kathy jeff
kyle and casey
were super helpful and last the
fabrication team
at mit architecture so christian shaw
zane jay and jeff thank you so much um
for making this possible and i think
with that
we might attempt screen share and
see how that goes first few words about
the design of the gallery itself
where you were interested in exploring
what this virtual format can afford us
given like the scale and materiality of
our work and the time-based media along
that comes along with it so we decided
to
go against this one-dimensional
experience based on scrolling and image
and image
grid layouts but we also didn't want to
go the other direction where we want
we create a like game like 3d
environment in the browser
yeah so instead what follows is a series
of rooms for those of you who haven't
been there
um it's sort of skeuomorphic and
familiar in the way it's constructed and
its first impression
but later it becomes de-familiarized as
you begin to explore the spaces a bit
more
and we focused on this non-linear
exploration
of the galleries and layering
information
in the design of the ui the user
interaction and
much like in physical galleries at first
you're immersed in this full screen
image and later you can sort of uncover
details and nested layers of information
and i think with that we can walk into
the first
room yeah so our title misalignment
is discussed in this first room
and interest it is is in the conditions
of misalignments
that are usually emerging around the
imprecise material assemblies and
engineering
the title brings us to the question of
exactitude
and ideal geometries which we
specifically wanted to interrogate
within the discipline of architecture
and to delve into that a little bit more
we wanted to
use the example of these standard size
bricks
the example of bricks and the history of
the mechanization of their
production introduces some of the key
concepts that this exhibition
works to destabilize so in the
development of bookmaking machines in
the us which happened throughout the
19th century
um this material clay was controlled
and made to conform to these ideal
orthogonal
preconceived geometries of a certain
size yeah ironically though these
actions that they
produce these precise geometries were
quite simple
they had to rely on this simplicity um
in this case pressing clay into a wooden
box to reproduce the standardized
dimension with intolerance
these low fidelity actions as we're
gonna start calling them
almost mechanical produce high
dimensional stability
by which we mean that the final break
conform to the
two by four by six that kind of
dimensions that they require
in standardized parts so here the crew
that you see
kind of also explains that as men
were molders who would scoop up enough
clay for about a brick and a half
press it firmly into a sand sprinkled
wooden box
divide it into big sized sections and
then scrape off any excess material so
it's a very low fidelity simple action
that you would have to perform
repetitively
can you all see the screen okay works
fine
okay so yeah
so oh sorry you're gonna go
i mean the more less exact diagram that
we show here
um expands this notion of exactness
based on the two criteria
that we mentioned before one that is
based on the analysis of fidelity of
actions
versus the dimensional stability
the first axis the vertical axis locates
the exactness in the dimensional
stability
how closely can you realize some
preconceived ideal geometry with
intolerance
typical of western architectural
practices these buildings that follow
this model are designed to
approximate some like very ideal
geometries
drawn in plan and sections through
cycles of building
and then also correction decay
maintenance and restoration
yeah so this is the first sort of
vertical axis
that you see here and on the other hand
this horizontal axis that we're
introducing
um sort of understands exactness in
terms of the fidelity of gestures
so as opposed to dimensions this is the
fidelity of actions
and for example in vernacular mod and
clay construction
the objective is not to achieve some
preconceived
ideal geometry and dimensions but rather
to find the form through layers of
carefully performed
actions even though these actions may
not seem dimensionally precise per se
these builders have a very fine-tuned
sensibility to the material that they're
working with
and their actions are precise in that
term
these precise actions allow the thin
structures to stand and not collapse
and in doing so they better adapt to the
material availability and
accommodate material qualities sometimes
letting the material qualities to emerge
rather than
suppressing it and so
throughout this show we're kind of
also working within this diagram
but different from what contemporary
digital fabrication projects
tend to do which tend to still inhabit
the first axis
and designers evaluate tools and designs
based
almost solely on dimensional stability
and they still aim to find ever final
layers for example
in 3d printed buildings almost
dematerializing
those buildings into pure geometries and
this is often at the expense of
resources
or overlooking material qualities that
we hope to
recover yeah and instead what we want to
explore
is how do we expand the spectrum
afforded by this diagram
what what does it mean like what if
instead of optimizing dimensions or even
actions we wandered into this space
more and more and sometimes you start
more and more and you go into this
other zone of the diagram what does it
mean to wander in this space as opposed
to always trying to optimize
always going into the finer finer
precision can we think of design as
trajectories rather than gold product
fixed in time and space so these are the
questions that we
um are revisiting in every room
essentially in different scales and so
in really basic terms our project
deals with these questions of tolerance
and we were using this industrial
robotic arm
and our own hand gestures and we were
trying to expand this definition of
exactness
so come up with something that's a more
um
that would admit more error in
error-prone processes
and we fabricated all of the objects in
the exhibition
either by hand or but this kuka kr6r900
industrial robotic arm that sits at the
mit architecture
department but these arms have
proliferated
in various design departments across the
country
diverting them from their original roles
in manufacturing
and while they were designed to perform
precise and complex actions in a loop
designers now push these robots to go
beyond this original aim of
optimizing and accelerating
manufacturing
yet still many of these practices still
follow
the first axis of dimensional stability
so
getting something to fit that prescribed
dimension as a model
and they often obscure the interventions
of the hands to create this illusion
of total automation yeah so we want to
kind of propose a different approach
that celebrates this interaction between
mechanical actions and
hand gestures
we developed machines and tools to
collaborate with these arms rather than
trying to always depend on the arm we
adapted traditional trimming and carving
tools as well as creating custom nozzles
and custom machines
even though they're kind of rudimentary
in the actions that it performs
these low tolerance machines are com
accommodates high tolerance gestures and
forms
we learn from existing open source
extruder designs and from the craft of
traditional ceramics together
and we decided to design our own tools
to expand and understand our design
space
so now we're going to be entering the
next room
so we'll get to see these machines at
work
so this next room we call the room of
actions
um this room gives you a glimpse at
or maybe a preview of some of the
emerging complex
formal language of these actions that we
explored and they kind of work with the
i mean traditional pottery techniques of
coiling and carving
or even stacking clay and so for example
these white coils here um
illustrate um this behavior of rope
coiling
which is a behavior that other
non-newtonian fluids also perform when
extruded so even glass or honey
and like honey dribbling these extruded
coils
fold swirl and then slowly solidify
into a seemingly precarious form
deviating heavily from the ideal
frequency form but still
finding stability in the end so
also i think we have some images of the
process and the nozzles
that we designed and we'll get back to
seeing this in action
in a bit and one other
example we wanted to bring up is the
carving
and the carving is kind of a risky
balancing act between material behavior
and prescribed geometry because
we the carving action removes the excess
material created by coiling
and it in a way gets closer to the
original prescribed form
or sometimes depending on the tolerances
of the coil form it can make a very
dramatic puncture
such as this opening so
[Music]
these this was the tool that we used to
carve this
form where we begin with this layer of
coiling actions that varies on the
tolerances
and as a result when you carve away from
this form
at some locations you get this very
uniform
surface qualities where in these other
cases where
because of the low tolerances of the
surface
that was developed before this creates a
very dramatic opening
so it's about calibrating those openings
and even though not
determining their size precisely
and in order to get and we'll let you
explore some of the other things in this
room later on but
to get here to these sort of complex
textures and layered actions um
we first mapped out the expanded space
of the diagram
um to create a series of objects that we
called experiments
which you see in this room um on this
platform so on this platform here
um the experiments populate the diagram
that you saw in the first room
and by fixing the ideal geometry but
these torqued ellipses
we were able to map out the different
qualities and textures and forms
and behaviors at the edges at all of the
edges and in the middle of this diagram
and you see on the lower left from
collapsing into the formless
on the upper in the upper right corner
to minimal
almost imperceptible layers that we
would normally define as
exact under i guess the axis of
dimensional stability
we kind of explore this whole space and
throughout that creation these objects
are not really fixed
in a particular form they can travel
in this diagram as long as they're kept
moist and they're not fired
and sometimes they can suddenly collapse
or you can even
carve away from them so as they go away
from
a certain degree of exactness they can
also come back to
to it so tolerance is also change
over time
so these are just some examples
yeah also in this gallery we wanted to
reveal something about the process of
creating this exhibition
[Music]
in order to bring our objects into
virtual spaces we actually had to create
digital copies of all of them
um exposing this digital materiality was
something that we thought it was
interesting to
expose the under side of it so to speak
and so this is essentially what's called
the texture map so this
is a square image that locates pixels
of the scanned mesh that you see earlier
to give it some um
[Music]
imitation or appearance of like giving
it a texture
that's lifelike texture and here where
we were interested in this idea of like
digital materiality
showing through and how that relates to
this like digital uh virtual exhibition
and how it
gives it the materiality
and it's sort of one attempt at
flattening these
two-dimensional objects here and also
gives you a peek at the
construction of the gallery itself and
from this room of experiments we'll go
over to the room of studies which
builds on the experiments similar to the
details that you saw earlier um
this moves beyond those single actions
and imbues those actions with intention
and layers them to create more complex
expressions
so for example this vault here
uses precise angles
to build an enclosure without any
additional
support and first it's coiled with a
nozzle
at specific angles to construct the
walls and then carving can create
openings
and remove some of the excess material
um yeah
and in this example we wanted to exploit
the idea of like
gradients and stability so where we
began on the bottom we had a very fine
layers
almost perceptible um and
we increased we modulated the layer
height so that we get this
change in the material behavior in the
middle and then
re retracting back to this original
condition
and this is kind of going beyond like
our initial
studies where we were fixing this kind
of um parameters
now we're playing with these parameters
to see what kind of qualities can
we can get out of
yeah and maybe last this this other
object um kind of
improvised we were interested in
hybridizing more explicitly
both hand and machine action so the
first layer
the bottom of this vault was hand
constructed and
3d scanned so it sort of went back and
forth between the digital
and the actual physical
construction and based on those first
couple layers
we then um found a form that would
create this enclosure
and slowly built it and we invite you to
explore
all these other objects in this room
um here if the earlier room where we
discussed about the texture maps was one
kind of flattening the scan meshes this
room presents
another way to capture in two dimensions
the tool path and the actions by the
bare hands
um these two are radically different
like one that's
seemingly very organized and regular and
there's this other
player where it seems very
chaotic these are
collaborative in a way that they reveal
the hands that assists and adjusts and
designs with
and sometimes altering the planning path
even if they're different these two
paths are very much coordinated
there are traces in like different
senses that what we had discussed
earlier
they don't draw the final object per se
but they show the dialogue
of the mechanical and mathematical
movements of the tool
and organic gestures of the hand
yeah and while this room um
i think captures these actions frozen in
time and flattened out
on these surfaces the next room
and the final room i will show you today
um shows the machines and the hand
in action in time so this is a little
video room
and this might be sort of
slow and jagged over our really slow
internet connection but we'll try to
play it and i think i didn't hit
optimize
for video so i could also just restart
the screen share
um but this might be a good
point too for us to stop and let the
videos speak for themselves
and open up for a q a yeah
thank you very much thank you all so
much for
coming out here i am just curious your
conception about how this research is
scalable
uh to architecture if you see this work
as ending in a theoretical space or
art object that contains an idea or
if you think that this a robotic
fabrication
of this type of material
could be done at a larger scale
i think there are attempts now that are
being
media in the media for example like the
mars project that
they um put it into
like discussions before um where they
are
attempts to go at a bigger scale
like of this technology itself but what
i think we are missing at the point is
again like this
expanded understanding of what why we
need to be always so precise and
can we go um beyond this like narrow
perception of the
exactness and i think in that sense it
exists
that question exists in any scale that
we were
working with but um we
we would love to try this at a larger
scale in fact
um we are trying to well i think
disgusted yeah
yeah i think we we discussed this a lot
of times both with the
different build spaces that we've been
in and
especially for this virtual exhibition
where we could have
easily made a larger inhabitable
structure of the same things that we've
been working on
um just by using the scans and that's i
mean scale is definitely something that
we could play with in a virtual setting
um
but we sort of naturally moved away from
that because i think
yeah i think while we would be
interested in maybe scaling them but it
would be a very different
um outcome from what you see in this
particular
show i think we would definitely um have
to rethink
a lot of things not just forms but even
what we're contributing to
that discussion beyond and
well i think they might these objects
even might be scalable as
wall sections or something like that um
i think what we're trying to think more
about
next is more about interaction with
the machine rather than making a
building out of this yeah because each
project that we
like that two different trajectories of
our project
takes a different amount of time in
terms of like
what we can achieve like if we were to
go big
right now then we would have to dedicate
a lot of time just to scale things up
without
really exploring further questions about
it
so right now i think as damma said our
next interest
is in the interactive part
tiandra has a question
what did you find most compelling about
the virtual exhibition that may not have
manifested in the original
physical version
yeah i think hi tiandra
thank you for the questions um yeah i
think one
um one thing i guess one thing i
mentioned that we didn't do
is scale up and use that idea of scaling
um for these objects one thing
that we played with was that non-linear
way of exploring and preventing people
from going backwards
which sort of gives these limitations
but also um
a unique phase of exploring
these different um galleries
and i think just setting up a very
conventional gallery setting which is
not at all what
these objects like something that these
objects speak against
was also an interesting part of it
yeah i mean one of our meta goal was to
think about yes like if you're doing
this in virtual
exhibition what can we get out of this
playing with this virtual exhibition as
a format and
you might have noticed that like the
gravity doesn't
hold true in this virtual exhibition
anymore as you
walk through a couple of different rooms
so that was like one
cute foray into like what are the bigger
questions that we can ask and like
um how do we represent drawings how do
we
represent models and like the 3d scan
became a
big protagonist in this where it became
it gave us this idea of like digital
materiality where you have to jump
through a lot of
loops of documenting it in 3d
scans that we didn't think of
and that's kind of already a part of our
process anyways
because we're always going back and
forth between the physical and the
virtual
even though it seems more physical
like when we carve an object we would
need to have a scan
of it in order to be able to carve it or
perform
any other actions on them
so that was interesting um we have
another
question oh yeah uh it looks like graham
has his hand raised
i do um i really enjoyed
how you found value in all the different
output in this project so whether it was
the experiments
getting their own room or
translating the 3d scan to a 2d
like a 2d image or the tool paths
um your ability to find
importance or to see what each of these
steps had to offer
was really inspiring to
like the process of of your process
is just exciting to me and so
um i want to commend you on that i would
love to hear you talk about
the scene um
in each of the not so much in this shot
but the
the the video that was playing prior to
this the tool pathing
will go to a point and then change
direction and go back and then change
direction so it goes counterclockwise
clockwise and in the in each of the um
experiments there's a distinct scene and
cue it up look at that um could you just
talk about
what its role in the project was and
i will mute and listen to your response
um
yeah i think it was a big question for
us that we never really
ever talked about i don't think um
but um normally people try to not have a
seam at all
they will just go in circles and
like slightly step up maybe just like a
really small gradient
all the way so it just seems like one
continuous
coiled thing and
i guess if you're minimizing the layers
then it's like completely
it's not noticeable at all and
we wanted to play with openings though
and especially with something that would
support
the weight of the clay on top of it like
in this case where it's becoming
this crazy opening here
not necessarily to make a door or
anything like that but just to
see if we could use this really unstable
way of making like closing up that seam
and the seam actually kind of goes
around the object so it
it kind of defines its own path yeah and
also
i wanted to show i think we need to look
a bit slow now yeah in the example in
the experiments
the seam itself helps to give it a
directionality between each layer so
some of them we the beaded we call
beaded one is
essentially done by um pausing after
after every um few seconds or something
and so because of that if you go in
one direction for some one layer and
then the other direction for
other um layer then you get this like
alternating effect
maybe not so visible in this one
but for example there was this
done on the same direction so like there
were
by introducing this like unstable
condition
we actually opened up a lot of like
different possibilities
rather than just giving you like a boss
like form
you can go back now and go back
so that was one of our intentions in
introducing the scene
and plus like it gives us like challenge
of
how do we make this structural like
if you can't rely on this being a closed
form
i think you can see it inside here but
not the best view
it um for me it acts as a
invitation um since the form isn't
closed
or closed in a traditional sort of sense
where
you would go in through the top um yeah
it acts
like as a viewer for me it acts as like
an invitation to to stay and look at
that object
and so by breaking my expectations of
the ceramic objects
it just holds my attention a little bit
longer
i enjoy that choice and then it sort of
trails through and and leaves its mark
around the whole project so uh thank you
for that
thank you see that maddie has her hand
raised
what's up i think we have also questions
in the chat hi
um i'm wondering if you can talk a
little bit about um kind of the process
of how you develop the different
materials that use it looks like there's
a lot of different types of clay and
different
materials used can you talk about like
where you started in the process of
deciding which of those were
helpful put in the gram i think
grams clay donations to us um
at first we had very little
understanding of clay the material
itself um and so we before even starting
this project
we just ended up signing up for
the ceramics class at saa and
actually learning a little bit about how
to like more traditional
um pottery techniques and hand building
and wheel throwing and we realized that
there's this
insanely broad and diverse world of
different
clay materials that it's not it's not
like there's one kind of you know clay
or ceramic material it's just a huge
range of things that each have their
specific qualities and a lot of these
objects
depend on those qualities to become what
they are so
and not only the actual raw material but
also
how moist it is and how it's mixed to
compose these objects was a huge part of
this
study and i think that's also why you
see um
these objects especially kind of
showcase all the different materials
that we tested
and i think it's still an open
exploration because they definitely
lead to such different outcomes yeah and
also
yeah we wanted to reiterate this that
the complexity
is in the material more than the
the machines themselves because there
are a lot of
um we when we were researching the
similar type of clay extruder
designs the consensus is that
the difficulty is in getting the clay
consistent
meaning like it wasn't the problem with
the machines themselves it was the
problem with the way that we
handled the material and the material is
like so
it can be so broad clay if you start
dissecting it is a combination of a lot
of different things
yep and so when we took the class at
harvard
we were also very curious can we mix
glass pieces into it can we
use the fire like pieces broken down
into smaller pieces and
what they call grog i guess can we
incorporate that into
giving us this like very smooth texture
versus like a very
rough texture like for example
these are very smooth because the grains
are fine
and this one for example we had like
paper clay in it like paper clay
paper fibers in it so when it's
extruding from the same extruder you get
this very different qualities
and so those are still open questions
and i think the design of that material
is like a critical yeah
great thank you i see that we also have
a question from
carla do you think it goes against the
machine's essence
in not being exact and how could that
redefine how we use machinery
i think it's not going against machines
as
essence and not being exact machines
have always been inexact
in the tolerance so the tolerance
has been getting smaller every iteration
of the
machine designs but essentially
how much error can you tolerate is the
question rather than the machine being
exact machines have there was this like
really interesting reading from
um i forgot the guy's name but
graham no um
i forgot the author's name but he was
discussing how
the most complex aircraft parts were
actually made
hammered by these like craftsmen when
the machines were
failing to produce like the super
precise geometry
um the craftsmans were able to see it
and like actually
through looking at their reflections
they were able to discern it way better
than the machines could do
so this is kind of like we're trying to
say machines are never that exact
like it's a conception that we have it's
a conception that the building should be
exact that we
want to dismantle and
i don't think it's going against the
essence
we we're trying to blend the essence
like
back to tiandra's other question
about if there's something to be learned
by a sculptor or potter
i guess we kind of semi-answered that by
saying that that's where we
started and we're not very good at it
yet but we're hoping to get back to it
once
i guess ceramics facilities reopen but
um
but i think there's definitely a lot of
exchange to be
made there and we actually as part of
the
harvard classes i think and also maybe
that could be a really cool thing to
have at mit as well
um but ceramics artists have been
working with
robots and working with architecture
students like
us um and sort of building that exchange
between the two disciplines and two
very different ways of thinking or
making um
and i think bringing those together is
really there's a really cool opportunity
for that
yeah totally i mean we we can't
emphasize how much we learn
before we even begin this from the clay
classes that we took at mit
shout out to stacy exactly
oh all right here we go andrea
our esteemed camp director says that she
is a great admirer of this project
because of how it complicates the
relationship
between the hand and the machine and
also because it's one of the first
projects that she's been able to follow
to fruition that was funded
by a camet grant could you reflect on
how that grant helped you extend beyond
where your thesis works stopped
and also everybody there's a camet plug
so please do check out the link in the
chat
i think we had um lots of plans for
um and like great opportunities also for
um for doing something very different
from what we had in mind initially
um and so as we were we were actually
about to go to
uh another facility in march
when and we did i think one shop
training
when mit closed um and
everything else closed and that facility
still hasn't reopened
um so so i think um
we ended up just the little time that we
had before that
um we worked on similar object i think
all of the larger
things that we made and the things in
the studies room
um but part of that exploration that we
began but um but that was i think
only one or two months after we
graduated
and then all of our plans were kind of
canceled by
covet closures and
we actually started working on
simulations and working with
this digital materiality of things when
we started talking with sarah
and heidi about maybe moving the gallery
to this virtual space which
ended up being like a really rich and
different format
that is in here only a part of this
project
but it's always in the background it's
always kind of hidden um
and throughout this
i guess thanks to having this
time when we're not making that many
things we have the time to think about
representing them and turning them into
this different
kind of experience yeah i mean also in
terms of grant
we were able to make much more um brave
choices in terms of
how the direction of this our thesis was
going to go
based on like this opportunity that we
got
and had we not had the grand for example
we wouldn't have been
brave enough to say let's try and make
our own machine you know
no and so yeah it was definitely
gave us like the launching pad for
um and i think yeah i think already
as part of our thesis we were kind of
preparing for this
exhibition um we always we had that in
mind um
and that's why we already had some of
our stands that sarah also mentioned in
the beginning
we were kind of ready to move into the
gallery but um
it's still in there i think
and it allowed us to go much bigger in
scale and much
braver in terms of designing machines
our displays
and we're really thankful for that yeah
thank you so much
i just wanted to say thank you so much
for for having us and i think tomorrow
we'll also have some really great events
so thank you all for coming out and
join arts and the radar tomorrow too
yeah
thank you so much everyone i would love
to echo that um
thank you all for attending thank you to
my co-host sarah thank you to tama and
jung
thank you for everybody in the office of
the arts for their fantastic rock star
support it was a long couple of hours
tonight
but it was full of so much great
programming i'm really proud of
everybody
um it's been a great kickoff to arts on
the radar like doma said
please be sure to come back and check
out our other panels and workshops
tomorrow
and like sarah said if you're interested
in any upcoming events in the wiesner
including exhibition opportunities
please follow the link in the chat
and have a fantastic evening everybody
we'll see you all tomorrow
thank you great job thanks so much
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
beautiful work guys thank you
you